NOW, WE'VE BEEN COVERING THE
FREDDIE GRAY CASE THIS WHOLE
WEEK, SO LAST NIGHT AFTER THE
SHOW I DECIDED THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE SHOULD TALK TO SOME ACTUAL
PROTESTERS.
SO I HOPPED ON A TRAIN TO
BALTIMORE-- THIS IS TRUE-- AND,
OF COURSE, AS SOON AS I DID,
THIS HAPPENED.
>> IN NEW YORK CITY,
DEMONSTRATORS CLASHED WITH
POLICE.
>> MORE THAN 100 PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED DURING THE PROTESTS IN
MANHATTAN.
>> Larry: COME ON, GUYS!
I JUST LEFT TOWN TO GO TO SOME
PROTESTING.
( LAUGHTER )
IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU WEREN'T
EVEN THINKING ABOUT "THE NIGHTLY
SHOW WITH LARRY WILMORE" AT ALL
WHEN YOU MADE YOUR "LET'S START
A PROTEST IN LARRY'S 'HOOD"
PLAN.
KNOW MY SCHEDULE, ALL RIGHT.
MAN. BUT OF ALL THE THINGS GOING
ON IN BALTIMORE
THE THING THAT FASCINATED ME THE
MOST WAS THIS GANG TRUCE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS HEARD
ABOUT IT, BUT EVERYBODY WAS
TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> RIVAL GANGS IT'S BLOODS,
CRIPS, AND BLACK GUERILLA
GANGS-- CALLING A TRUCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY.
THE REAL PROBLEM THEY SAY IS
DECADES OF POVERTY AND POLICE
BRUTALITY
>> Larry: YOU KNOW THE COPS
ARE RUNNING WILD WHEN GANG
LEADERS START SOUNDING LIKE NOAM
CHOMSKY BY COMPARISON.
THAT'S PRETTY BAD, MAN.
SO ANYWAY, LAST NIGHT, I HEADED
DOWN TO BALTIMORE, AND I SAT
DOWN IN A DINER WITH SOME RIVAL
GANG MEMBERS WHO CALLED A TRUCE,
AND WE ATE A LITTLE PIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
I'M HERE WITH SOME OF THE
BROTHERS WHO ARE HERE IN
BALTIMORE HERE DOING ALL THE
UPRISING, THE UNREST.
HAVE YOU GUYS EATEN YOU HAVE
LOOKED AT THE MENU?
>> I ALREADY KNOW WHAT I WANT.
>> Larry: CAN WE HAVE A
WAITRESS IN HERE.
WHO BROUGHT YOU GUYS TOGETHER?
>> I HAVE KNOWN THIS BROTHER A
LONG TIME.
KNOWN THIS BROTHER A LONG TIME
>> HOW LONG YOU HAVE KNOWN HIM.
>> LIKE FOUR YEARS.
>> FOUR YEARS.
>> Larry: IN GANG TIME,
THAT'S LIKE 18 YEARS, RIGHT.
SO ARE YOU GUYS IN THE SAME
ORGANIZATION OR DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS.
>> NO, THE SAME ORGANIZATION.
>> Larry: SAME ORGANIZATION.
YOU'RE THE SAME.
YOU'RE NOT IN THE ORGANIZATION.
>> I'M COOL WITH EVERYBODY.
>> Larry: HE'S COOL WITH
EVERYBODY.
>> HE'S COOL WITH EVERYBODY.
>> Larry: SO YOU GUYS HAVE
CALLED A TRUCE-- WAIT, IS IT A
TRUCE OR A TREATY?
IT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE RATIFIED BY
CONGRESS OR ANYTHING.
>>
>> NO,.
>> Larry: BECAUSE JOHN BOEHNER
IS AN [BLEEP] I'LL TELL YOU NOW
>> WE DIDN'T HAVE A TRUCE OR
TREATY.
WE HAD MEN RESPECTING MEN AS MEN
AND WE DID IT JUST LIKE THAT.
>> I WAS WALKING AND WE WAS ALL
IN A PACK DOWN FULTON AVENUE
AND ONE THE BLOOD HOMIES STEPPED
ON MY SHOE. AND I LOOKED AT HIM
AND SAID YOU KNOW 3 DAYS AGO I'D
HAVE HIT YOU IN THE MOUTH FOR
THAT? AND HE SMILED.
>> Larry: THREE DAYS FROM NOW
THINGS MIGHT BE BACK TO NORMAL
AND YOU CAN HIT HIM IN HIS MOUTH
AGAIN.
>> NO, HE'S GOOD.
>> Larry: THAT'S GOOD.
THE TRUCE IS GOOD.
IT'S FOREVER NOW, RIGHT?
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE SAYING?
>> AS FAR AS US.
WE CAN'T SPEAK FOR WHOLE
COUNTRY, BUT AS FAR AS
BALTIMORE, WHAT WE'RE DOING,
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING.
WE START WITH US.
>> Larry: WHERE DO YOU GUYS
THINK THE ANGER IN THE COMMUNITY
COMES FROM?
WHERE TO YOU THINK THAT COMES
FROM?
>> THE ANALOGY I'VE BEEN
USING IS, NOW YOU SEE THIS
CORNER ON THE MENU? THIS IS A
CORNER.
THIS IS A PERSON.
THIS IS YOU.
IT'S ONLY SO FAR BACK INTO THIS
CORNER YOU CAN PUSH ME BEFORE I
HAVE TO PUSH BACK.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
THEY PUSHED BACK.
>> Larry: THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF
AMERICA CAN'T RELATE TO RIGHT
NOW.
THEY CAN'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> OF COURSE NOT. IF YOU LIVE IN
A MILLION-DOLLAR HOUSE
HOW CAN YOU RELATE TO LIVING IN
THE HOOD AND GETTING PUSHED?
YOU'RE GOOD. YOU CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH. SAME, AS WHEN YOU'RE
LIKE MAN, I HAVE TO PAY MY
PROPERTY TAX. I CAN'T RELATE TO
THAT.
I NEVER PAID PROPERTY TAX
BEFORE.
>> Larry: I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT
THE ANGER OF THE PROPERTY TAX.
SO LET'S SAY THIS IS MY
MILLION-DOLLAR HOUSE, OKAY.
( LAUGHTER )
AND THE PROPERTY TAX IS PUSHING
ME INTO THIS CORNER.
THAT'S WHEN I GET ANGRY.
( LAUGHTER )
THAT'S WHEN I BURST.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T RELATE TO
THAT.
>> YOU CALL A LAWYER AND YOU
PUSH BACK.
EXACTLY.
>> Larry: AND THEN IT'S A
VICIOUS CYCLE.
HAVE YOU GUYS EVER STOPPED
SOMEBODY FROM DOING SOMETHING,
LIKE PHYSICALLY STOPPED SOMEBODY
FROM THROWING SOMETHING?
>> I WHOOPED SOMEBODY'S ASS
>> DID YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT CAME UP ON
THE AVENUE, WEREN'T FROM THERE.
>> Larry: SO THERE WERE PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T EVEN FROM AROUND
THERE.
>> IT WAS LITTLE KIDS
>> IT WAS ALSO PEOPLE --
>> HOW OLD WERE THEY?
>> HIGH SCHOOL, LIKE, MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
>> THEY STARTED--
>> I SAW JON STEWART OUT THERE.
>> Larry: YOU SAW JON STEWART
OUT THERE.
>> I'M STANDING IN FRONT OF THE
SCHOOL, ME AND A COUPLE OF
HOMIES.
>> Larry: OK, SCOOBY AND
A COUPLE OF HOMIES
STANDING IN FRONT OF THE STORE.
>> JON STEWART IS RIGHT BEHIND
US.
>> JON STEWART IS NOT HERE.
TRUST ME.
TRUST ME ON THAT.
HE IS NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
>> THE POLICE PULL UP IN A TANK.
>> Larry: A TANK, LIKE ONE OF
THOSE BIG HUMVEES.
>> THEY COME OUT WITH THEIR
ASSAULT RIFLES.
AND I WAS LIKE, "MAN, THIS IS
'CALL OF DUTY'."
>> Larry: THEY JUMPED OUT.
THEY DID, THEY POINT THEIR GUNS
AND ALL THAT AND I GOT HIT WITH
A CONCUSSION GRENADE. I GOT
HOLES ALL IN MY FAVORITE HOODIE
>> Larry: WAIT, THAT HAPPENED
THIS PAST WEEK?
YOU GOT HIT WITH A CONCUSSION
GRENADE?
>> TWO DAYS AGO. THEY THREW IT
RIGHT TOWARDS US AND WE WERE
PROTECTING THE STORES
>> IT HIT ME RIGHT IN THE RIBS.
>> WE WERE MAKING SURE THERE WAS
NO LOOTING
>> WE RAN THROUGH THE
ALLEY, TO
THE PROJECTS, MADE SURE EVERYONE
ELSE WAS OKAY AND WENT RIGHT
BACK TO OUR POST AND LINKED ARMS
AND MADE SURE NOBODY GOT IN THAT
STORE.
>> Larry: WOW.
>> THEY SET ONE POLICE CAR ON
FIRE AND WE STOPPED THEM FROM
SETTING THE OTHER CAR ON FIRE.
>> Larry: WOULD YOU GUYS EVER
MEET WITH THE POLICE?
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: YOU TALKED TO THEM?
>> EVERY DAY, WE WALK RIGHT PAST
THEM.
WE ASKED, "ARE YOU GOOD?
DO YOU NEED WATER?"
>> Larry: WHAT WAS YOUR
REACTION.
>> THEY DID BRING US FOOD.
>> Larry: THEY BROUGHT YOU
FOOD?
>> I COULDN'T-- I COULDN'T EAT
THE SANDWICHES BECAUSE THEY HAD
PORK. SO I HAD TO EAT FIVE BAGS
OF CHIPS
>> Larry: I COULD DO A PIG
JOKE.
WHAT'S THE MOST SURPRISING THING
THAT CAME OUT OF ALL OF THIS?
>> ALL THE POSITIVE PEOPLE
COMING TOGETHER.
IT WAS FOR ONE COMMON CAUSE-- IT
WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> Larry: DO YOU GUYS HAVE
HOPE?
>>, OF COURSE,.
>> OF COURSE,.
>> WHAT ELSE DO WE GOT?
>> Larry: YOU HAVE HOPE, SEAN?
>> THAT'S THE ONLY THING YOU
HAVE TO HAVE IF YOU WANT TO
PROGRESS.
>> Larry: I THINK WE HAVE-- I
THINK WE HAVE PIE COMING RIGHT
NOW.
SEAN DOESN'T LIKE PORK, SO MAKE
SURE SEAN DOESN'T GET THE PORK.
YOU GUYS HAVE REALLY BEEN GREAT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION WITH ME.
IS THERE ANY OTHER THING YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SAY EITHER TO
AMERICA, TO PEOPLE WATCHING THIS
PROGRAM?
>> I WANT EVERYBODY TO KEEP
THEIR HOPE, AND STAY PEACEFUL.
I MEAN, WHEN-- WHEN THEY HEAR
THE POLICE VERDICT FRIDAY,
DON'T GIVE UP BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
THE LAST OF THE INVESTIGATION.
IT'S A LOT MORE INVESTIGATIONS
AFTER THAT.
( APPLAUSE )
KEEP THE HOPE.
>> Larry: ARE WE SPLITTING
THIS SIX WAYS?
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW WE'RE
GOING.
>> YEAH. LET'S SEE HOW MANY
POCKETS YOU'VE GOT
>> Larry: YOU DON'T HAVE,
LIKE, A CORPORATE CREDIT CARD
THAT YOU USE?